I've been an entrepreneur my whole life
I started my first company when I was 15
and now I'm about to graduate from
Babson College very nice I'm deeply
passionate thank you
I am deeply passionate about tech
startup I am actually in the middle of
building my fourth company right now I
know in the future I want to end up
basically where you are investing
preferably my own money as a start-up so
I think are super unique and hopefully
as a full-time job fantastic I know that
the quickest or most typical way is to
build a company sell it for an enormous
amount of money obviously but I realize
I need to pay my bills until I have the
traction to attract invest investors
like you so I'm looking at my graduation
as an opportunity to find a one or two
year stepping stone that will truly make
me a better entrepreneur I've been
thinking a lot about going to do
associate or honestly any work for a VC
firm instead of a typical Apple Facebook
Google job but I've gotten advice from
other investors and entrepreneurs who
you know are obviously very successful
as well they basically have advised me
to either join some sort of pre see
where I'd have a lot of impact or to
join a series B to D the growth stage
company where you know they're growing
exponentially or I can learn but I'm
really having trouble a hard time rather
weighing my impact at a company versus
learning from the companies that are
growing exponentially with or without me
so my question is this is if you were to
give advice to young Jason who was about
to graduate college in 2019 what would
you recommend he prioritize in terms of
a first career great question so when I
was coming up in New York I had a
consulting gig for Fred Wilson and Jerry
Colonna with their acne ventures which
lady became flatiron partners and I was
writing coverage for them at the age of
24 25 about startups and instead of
going into venture at that time when I
was two
4:25 I went into the media business cuz
I had a passion for magazines looking
back on it it would have been better for
me to go venture in terms of probably
net worth but I loved magazines I liked
media and so I don't regret it it kind
of made me famous to have my own
magazine in New York I got a lot of
press so I try not to overthink these
things of what I would change in my
career I kind of like being a venture
capitalist right now I liked being a
magazine publisher and editor back then
for you number one thanks for being a
capitalist thanks for creating wealth
and jobs in the world thanks for not
being a socialist who wants a handout
I'm just our trough right there with
triggering all the libs who want to you
know believe that it can't be done you
can you know make a great future for
yourself but it requires you having a
skill and so you know it's and you got a
you got a great college or coming out of
that helps on the margins right people
you can't be a Shema can go to maps and
I don't think that's possible
and you've started some companies so the
real question is are you more passionate
about starting companies do you have a
company that you really need to see in
the world manifest itself or are you
more passionate about maybe investing
right or do you just want to invest
because you want to be rich if you
really have that passion for investing
I think the hack today I'm gonna give
you like three hacks the first hack is
startups are about growth right startups
are not about just building a
world-class product anymore it used to
be like we were kind of in the startup
game seeing if we could build a product
to see if it existed in the world but
that has left the station now like
everybody can make a great world-class
product the secrets are all out there if
you just go online you can learn how to
make a great app learn how to make a
great service so really and and to do a
cheaper in fact so what is left is
growth so if I were to pick one skill
for you it would be being a director of
growth where a vice president of growth
or a growth hacker just any way for you
to be able to say I was at this startup
and then I left for this startup and I
handled growth
I made the regice
I made the number of users go up I
learned all these techniques because
what people are looking for in venture
capitalists right now and investors are
investors who can unlock those secrets
those techniques and get around a table
and figure out how to grow a startup
I've recently wrote a blog post over
Calacanis calm about the one way to
guarantee you're gonna get funded
forever and that is if you triple double
or triple revenue every year if you
double revenue really six months if you
double revenue every six months you
triple it every 12 months you will get
unlimited funding if you're one of the
people who can enable a startup to do
that you are invaluable in value Bo and
that is the skill that you really want
to have is that ability to make things
grow so that's what I would suggest for
you is to figure out how to make things
grow getting like a job as an analyst at
a venture firm it's kind of hard you can
take a shot at it those positions are
hard to get but you might get one it's
just very very difficult and I think a
lot of the founders who want money from
investors today will look around the
table and say okay the partners in your
firm have any of them built anything and
if you look at a firm like in recent
Horowitz they just hired a friend of
mine David you Levitch who built a
company for ten years or more and now
he's a partner there so when and I was
talking to a founder last night it was
like hey do you think I should take
money from you Jason Horowitz I'll say
well what's the partner I'm not sure and
I was just counseling them on stuff he
said and he mentioned it was David you
Levitch and I said yeah well he built
this company and then I was like oh I
love that company oh yeah no I I could
see myself working with them so that's
your first act is getting into growth a
second potential hack to get into this
might be to look at investors out there
and see if you could become their
analyst chief of staff and to prove it
to them and say to them hey I know I'm
gonna pick somebody cyan banasur had
found his phone hey cyan I'm a huge fan
I know you invested in uber and I know
you recently invested in the company
density I did some research for you and
I found these six potential competitors
for density
I found these six different
opportunities and I summarized it for
you in this Google Doc I would like to
do this for you every day you find an
opportunity I write coverage for you and
here's how I did it and you could look
up the YouTube deal memo that rule off
both the road at Sequoia just Google
that rule of both Bo tha and YouTube
deal memo and when you read that you
could just start writing those and
sending them to people now what you're
doing is you're showing investors
instead of asking for the job and saying
trust me I can do it you're saying Here
I am doing the job look at the work
product here it is I did it and that
shows hustle and it shows dexterity that
you can actually do it so those are my
two number my number one and my number
two for you spend two or three years
doing growth at startups go to every
accelerator you can think of tech stars
why comedy or launch accelerator look at
the companies coming out of those great
programs pick one that you think you
love and email the founder and say I
want to work on growth I'll work for any
dollar amount doesn't matter I want to
help you grow the company I'm looking to
get my break here I'll learn on the job
and the second is to just write coverage
of companies etc and email it to
somebody if you were instead of calling
me and talking about this if you had
sent me an email I said Jason I wrote
coverage of all the cafe X competitors I
could find and all of the calm calm
opportunities I could find and here's my
analysis and I read it and it was good
analysis mmm maybe I should hire this
kid right so those are my two ideas for
you